Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club first came here, 1900 years ago, the other day. Imagine the feelings of the commander of a fine, what do you call them, trireme in the Mediterranean, ordered suddenly to the north. Or think of a decent young citizen in a toga, perhaps too much dice, you know, coming out here in the train of some prefect. Land in a swamp, march through the woods, and in some inland post, feel the savagery, the utter savagery had closed around him. All that mysterious life of the wilderness that stirs in the forest, in the jungles,
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、享受无广告体验、抢先收听系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。这里是1900年前，也就是前几天，人们第一次抵达的地方。想象一下，在地中海指挥一艘精良的——你们管那叫什么来着——三列桨座战船的指挥官，突然接到命令北上时的心情。或者想象一下，一个穿着托加长袍、可能沉迷于掷骰子的体面年轻公民，跟随某位长官来到这里。降落在沼泽地，穿过树林，在某个内陆哨所，感受到那种野蛮，那种彻底的野蛮将他包围。荒野中所有那些在森林里、在丛林中涌动的神秘生命，
in the hearts of wild men. Imagine the growing regrets, the longing to escape, the powerless disgust, So Tom Hollands, that's how I feel when I come to London. That quotation from Heart of Darkness by Joseph Conrad, in which Marlow, the narrator, imagines the feelings of a Roman, a young Roman, posted to Britannia. What a god-awful posting that is. And he ends up in London of all places. Well, I think, I think Dominic, it's, it's actually imagining, um, a Roman coming up the Thames estuary before London has even been founded. Um, and we, uh, today we're going on a tour of roman london of londinium but i think
在野蛮人的心中。想象一下那种与日俱增的悔恨、逃离的渴望、无能为力的厌恶。汤姆·霍兰德，这就是我来伦敦时的感觉。那段引自约瑟夫·康拉德《黑暗之心》的文字，书中叙述者马洛想象了一个被派往不列颠尼亚的年轻罗马人的感受。那是一个多么糟糕的驻地啊。而他最终竟然被派到了伦敦。嗯，我想，我想多米尼克，这实际上是在想象，嗯，一个罗马人沿着泰晤士河口向上游航行，那时伦敦甚至还没有建立。嗯，我们，呃，今天我们要去参观罗马伦敦，也就是伦底纽姆，但我认为
that the part of the fascination of roman london for anyone who has you know who's apocalyptically minded is the sense that um there was a time when this huge city didn't exist and it's entirely a creation of the romans and then of course after after the Romans leave, it collapses and crumbles again. And Conrad is writing that at a time when, you know, London is the great imperial capital of the world's largest empire, larger than Rome. It is the new Rome. And it's prefiguring the story of Marlow going up the Congo. Yeah. You know, the heart of darkness and i think that we're standing now on london bridge the south side of london bridge set the scene for us tell us what we can see got some pools over on the horizon the great dome the symbol of the blitz and all that stuff yeah so
罗马伦敦对任何有末日情结的人来说，其魅力的一部分在于那种感觉，即曾经有一个时期，这座巨大的城市并不存在，它完全是罗马人的创造，然后当然，在罗马人离开后，它又坍塌并化为废墟。康拉德写作时，伦敦正是世界上最大的帝国——比罗马还要大——的伟大帝国首都。它是新罗马。这预示了马洛前往刚果的故事。是的。你知道，黑暗之心，我想我们现在正站在伦敦桥上，伦敦桥的南侧，为我们布置一下场景，告诉我们能看到什么。地平线上有一些起重机，那座大圆顶，闪电战的象征，诸如此类。是的，所以
we so so we're on london bridge we've got the thames flowing the vastness of the thames we've got um we've got uh the embankment has been built up, we've got the great kind of monuments to Mammon, the great, the great towers of the city, and then we've got the Tower of London on the right side and Tower Bridge. But thinking about Roman London takes us back to a time when none of this existed, when there were no wharfs, there were no build-up, the Thames was was kind of great bog and the reason that we're standing here now and the reason that london exists is because it's crucially this is the lowest bridging point on the thames where we are now yeah so when the
我们，我们，我们现在在伦敦桥上，泰晤士河在流淌，泰晤士河的浩瀚，我们有，嗯，我们有，呃，堤岸已经筑起，我们有那些伟大的玛门纪念碑，城市里那些伟大的、伟大的塔楼，然后我们在右侧看到了伦敦塔和塔桥。但思考罗马伦敦会把我们带回到一个这一切都不存在的时代，那时没有码头，没有建筑群，泰晤士河就像是一片大沼泽。我们现在站在这里的原因，以及伦敦存在的原因，是因为这里至关重要，这是泰晤士河上最低的过河点，我们现在就在这里。是的，所以当
romans land here ad 43 they need to cross the thames and probably this was a fording point where we're standing now it's a hell of a long ford tom i mean it is a long way it is a long ford but they had they had batavians who came from uh batavia from the from the netherlands uh from the low countries who were very adept the producers very amused by that giggling away but they shouldn't be because the batavians were serious guys who um they they could cross rivers in full armor with their horses that is impressive so they were able to do that and get across but it very very quickly the romans built a bridge here and on the far side roads were then built going to northwards westwards um so you were telling me nobody it hasn't occurred to the celts to i mean if it if it's a fording point, there must be some, is there a settlement?
罗马人在公元43年登陆这里时，他们需要跨越泰晤士河，可能我们现在站的地方就是一个涉渡点。汤姆，这可是一段很长的涉渡路程。我的意思是，这确实很长，这是一个很长的涉渡点，但他们有巴达维亚人，他们来自呃巴达维亚，来自荷兰，来自低地国家，他们非常擅长……制作人对那个笑得很开心，但他们不应该笑，因为巴达维亚人是严肃的人，他们，他们可以穿着全套盔甲带着马匹过河，这令人印象深刻。所以他们能够做到这一点并渡过河去，但很快，罗马人就在这里建了一座桥，在河对岸，道路随后向北、向西延伸。所以你刚才告诉我，没人……凯尔特人没想到……我的意思是，如果这是一个涉渡点，那一定会有一些……这里有定居点吗？
As far as we know, there was an operdum, so a kind of a hill fort, a kind of proto-town at Woolwich. Right. But no other settlement, really. I mean, maybe the odd farm, but essentially that description that Conrad gives you of the trireme coming up the Thames estuary and looking out and seeing nothing but savagery and barbarism. I mean, it wasn't, but we're talking mudflats, we're talking forests. There's nothing here.
据我们所知，那里有一个奥皮杜姆（Oppidum），也就是一种山堡，一种伍尔维奇的原型城镇。没错。但真的没有其他定居点。我的意思是，也许有个别农场，但本质上，康拉德描述的那种三列桨座战船沿着泰晤士河口向上航行，放眼望去除了野蛮和未开化什么也看不到的景象。我的意思是，事实并非如此，但我们说的是泥滩，我们说的是森林。这里什么都没有。
And this is what makes London unusual in the Roman context, is that by and large, when the Romans move into a place, they set their provincial capital up in a place that is already a major center. Right. So trading. Absolutely. So the major settlement in Britain when the Romans invade is Camulodonum Colchester. So that Colchester duly becomes the first capital. But London is kind of great. So, you know, the famous description of London is that it's the great when a kind of great pustule or boil or spot that grows on the country and that works perfectly as well in the roman period because there's there's no plan to build a founder city here it just grows organically why because this is the lowest bridging point as we said and the bridge
这就是伦敦在罗马背景下不同寻常之处，因为总的来说，当罗马人进入一个地方时，他们会把省会设在一个已经是主要中心的地方。没错。也就是贸易中心。绝对是。所以当罗马人入侵时，不列颠的主要定居点是卡姆罗多努姆（科尔切斯特）。所以科尔切斯特理所当然地成为了第一个首都。但伦敦有点……所以，你知道，关于伦敦著名的描述是，它是一个伟大的……当一种巨大的脓疱、疖子或斑点在国家上生长时，这在罗马时期也完全适用，因为这里没有建造或建立城市的计划，它只是自然生长。为什么？因为这是我们所说的最低过河点，而桥
is built here but it's also a port so you can sail up here. So that is what makes London, and has always made London, the obvious capital once you have a unitary state in southern Britain. Because this is kind of made by geography to be the capital. And that essentially, so it kind of grows organically in a way that by and large in Roman Britain most cities don't. Most cities here are artificial. We're about halfway over the bridge now, heading towards the city. Tell us a bit more about the people who lived here when the Romans arrived.
建在这里，但它也是一个港口，所以你可以航行到这里。这就是伦敦之所以成为伦敦的原因，而且一旦你在不列颠南部拥有了一个统一的国家，它就一直是显而易见的首都。因为地理位置注定了它要成为首都。所以它基本上是以一种在罗马不列颠的大多数城市中并不常见的方式自然生长起来的。这里的大多数城市都是人为的。我们现在走到桥的一半了，正前往城市。再多告诉我们一些关于罗马人到达时住在这里的人们的情况。
So they're Celtic. Yeah. And the sort of stereotype is basically they're painted blue, you know, daubing each other in mud. Drinking milk. Yeah. Absolutely vile customs. Just behaving disgracefully.
所以他们是凯尔特人。是的。刻板印象基本上是他们涂着蓝色，你知道，互相涂抹泥巴。喝牛奶。是的。绝对恶心的习俗。行为极其恶劣。
Yes, shocking. No, they're mud. Drinking milk. Yeah. Absolutely vile customs. Just behaving disgracefully. Yes, shocking. No, they're a bit more civilised than that. They are, you know, they're on the periphery of a great empire. And so, like most people's on the periphery of a great empire, they're influenced by it. So they're starting to invest in wine. They're starting to copy things like coinage. There may well actually be tribal entities here who have already essentially submitted to the Romans
是的，令人震惊。不，他们比那文明一点。他们，你知道，处于一个大帝国的边缘。所以，就像大多数处于大帝国边缘的人民一样，他们受到了影响。所以他们开始投资葡萄酒。他们开始模仿货币之类的东西。这里很可能已经有部落实体在正式入侵之前就已经基本上向罗马人投降了。
even before the formal invasion. Why do the Romans bother? I know that's a huge question, and we don't want to have it dominate the whole episode, but in a couple of lines, this is not a very, you know, as the Conrad description suggests, it's not a terribly attractive part of Europe. They're so rich already and powerful.
为什么罗马人要费这个劲？我知道这是一个巨大的问题，我们不想让它主导整个节目，但简单说几句，正如康拉德的描述所暗示的那样，这并不是欧洲一个特别吸引人的地方。他们已经非常富有和强大了。
Why do they even bother? Well, Britain is actually very, I mean, it's agriculturally rich. It's full of minerals. Tin. It is also, it's there. And empires expand. Okay. And Claudius, the emperor who launches the invasion you know he
他们为什么要费这个劲？嗯，不列颠实际上非常，我的意思是，它农业富饶。它充满了矿产。锡。而且，它就在那里。帝国总是会扩张的。好吧。而克劳狄，那个发动入侵的皇帝，你知道他
famously uh people who've watched like claudius will know he he stutters he limps his head rolls um he wants to to cut a dash yeah he needs it for political reasons he needs it for political reasons um and and so actually the very first representation of Britannia, so the figure who appears on our coins. Yeah. It appears on a frieze in a temple in what's now Turkey. And it shows Claudius as a kind of iron bodied rapist. He's raping her. So Britannia is a woman.
著名地，呃，看过《我，克劳狄》的人都知道，他口吃，他跛脚，他的头摇晃，嗯，他想出风头。是的，他出于政治原因需要它。他出于政治原因需要它。嗯，所以实际上，不列颠尼亚的第一个形象，也就是出现在我们硬币上的那个形象。是的。它出现在现在土耳其境内一座神庙的浮雕上。它展示了克劳狄作为一个铁躯的强奸者。他在强奸她。所以不列颠尼亚是一个女人。
She's had her clothes torn off. Claudius is holding her. And that's essentially why Claudius launches it. He needs a coup. He wants people to do mosaics and freezes like that about him, basically. He does. He wants to cut a dash. He wants to pose as an imperator, a general, an emperor. An emperor has that kind of root in the military sense of it. So, Tom, we're now on the just reaching the other side of the Thames, the north side. So at what point would you say do the Romans identify this as a future settlement? So within,
她的衣服被撕破了。克劳狄抱着她。这基本上就是克劳狄发动入侵的原因。他需要一场政变。他希望人们为他制作那样的马赛克和浮雕，基本上就是这样。他确实想。他想出风头。他想以统帅、将军、皇帝的身份摆姿势。皇帝在军事意义上就有那种根基。所以，汤姆，我们现在刚到达泰晤士河的另一边，北岸。那么你会说罗马人在什么时候将其确定为未来的定居点？是在登陆几年内，还是？是的，正如我所说，我认为它是自然生长起来的。所以它变成了一个军事基地。他们在这里建了一个堡垒。它控制着，你知道，通往大陆的通道。是的。所以有一份被发现的文件，其日期非常早。所以可能在公元47年，这里就建起了一座木桥。好吧。所以那是……什么，在三四年之内？是的。所以是在入侵后的三四年。在入侵后的三四年，然后在那之后的10年，我们可以非常精确地将其定在公元57年1月8日，你有一张借据，也就是有人承诺还钱。你意识到的是，所以我们
you know, a few years of landing or is it? Yeah, as I said, I think it grows up organically. So it becomes a military base. They build a fort here. It controls, you know, the access to the continent. Yeah. So there's a document that's been found that dates from incredibly early on. So probably the bridge is built, a wooden bridge is here by 47. Okay. So that's... What, within like three or four years? Yeah. So three or four years after the invasion. three or four years after after the invasion and then 10 years after that and we can date it very precisely to the 8th of january ad 57 you have an iou so somebody promising to pay money back and what you realize is so we're
我们现在正进入城市，我们被，你知道，这些闪闪发光的塔楼、赚钱的纪念碑所包围。伦敦，从一开始，就是为了赚钱。所以商人们来到这里。城市的精神从未改变。城市的精神从未改变。罗马人在看到战略上至关重要的交通和军事节点时，是能够欣赏的。
we're now crossing into the city and we're surrounded by you know these great gleaming towers monuments to money-making. London, right from the beginning, has been about making money. So traders are coming in here. The ethos of the city has never changed. The ethos of the city has never changed. The Romans can appreciate a strategically crucial transport and military node when they see it.
这就是为什么到……当然是到一世纪末，很明显它已经取代科尔切斯特成为该省的首都，因为它，你知道，它是显而易见的首都。但当然，在那之前，多米尼克，发生了淹没伦敦的众多灾难中的第一起，它发生在公元60年或61年，也就是布狄卡起义。我们现在将前往银行地铁站，服务于英格兰银行。那里有一段路叫家禽街（Poultry）。所以在中世纪，那是卖鸡的地方。而家禽街1号在80年代和90年代进行了重建。
And that's why by the end of, certainly by the end of, certainly by the end of the first century, it's pretty clear that it's replaced Colchester as the capital of the province because it's, you know, it is the obvious capital. But of course, before that, Dominic, there is the first of one of the many catastrophes that have overwhelmed the city of London, which hits it in either 80, 60 or 61, which is, of course, Boudicca's revolt. We will head now up towards Bank, Bank Tube Station, serving the Bank of England. And there is a stretch of road there called Poultry. So in the Middle Ages, that's where chickens were sold. And number one poultry was redeveloped in the 80s and 90s.
在重建过程中，发现了一些非凡的东西。所以让我们等到我们到达那里，然后我们可以讨论它。那太令人兴奋了。所以，汤姆，在外行看来，我们似乎刚刚停在了一家国民西敏寺银行（NatWest）分行外面。向我解释一下这个地点背后的惊人故事。好的，我们现在看到的是家禽街1号，它是由詹姆斯·斯特林设计的。它在这里建造的整个过程非常有争议，因为它位于马芬和韦伯（Maffin and Webb）的旧址上，那是一座非常漂亮的维多利亚式建筑。但从罗马考古学的角度来看，这很棒，因为他们向下挖掘
And during the process of redevelopment, something extraordinary was found. So let's wait till we get there and then we can discuss it. That is very exciting. So, Tom, to unwitting eyes, it would seem that we've just stopped outside a branch of NatWest. Explain to me the thrilling story behind this spot. OK, so we're now looking at number one poultry, which was designed by James Sterling. The whole process by which it came to be built here was very controversial because it was on the site of Maffin and Webb, which is a very handsome Victorian building. But from the point of view of Roman archaeology, it was great because they dug down
在地基里，他们发现了48个头骨，全是年轻男性的，显然是被斩首并扔在那里的，还有烧焦的建筑物。这些建筑的年代可以追溯到公元60年左右。所以这就是塔西佗关于布狄卡起义的报告中提到的证据，她焚毁了伦敦。
and in the foundations, they found 48 skulls, all of young men, so clearly being decapitated and dumped there, and charred buildings. And these buildings have dated to around AD 60. So this is the evidence for what you get in Tacitus, the report of Boudicca's revolt, that she incinerates London.
伦敦已经被烧毁了三次。这是第一次。然后，当然，你有1666年的伦敦大火，然后你有闪电战。而之所以，嗯，这被保存下来，是因为你会看到我们正站在一条叫沃尔布鲁克（Walbrook）的街道上，沃尔布鲁克是一条就在我们脚下流淌的河流，所以它是一条消失的河流，对吧，它是一条消失的河流。所以我们所在的银行，英格兰银行就矗立在沃尔布鲁克河之上。它实际上是在一个河谷里。
And London has kind of been burnt three times. This was the first. Then, of course, you have the Great Fire, 1666, and then you have the Blitz. And the reason that um this was preserved is because of you'll see we're standing on a street called walbrook and the walbrook is a river that is running directly beneath us so it's a lost river right it's a lost river so the place we're by bank the bank of eng, and the Bank of England stands over the Walbrook. It's actually in a river valley.
所以我们在拉德盖特山和康希尔之间。你永远不会知道，对吧？你永远不会知道。所以这条河在泰晤士河以北约两英里半处发源，向正南流去。罗马城市基本上围绕着它聚集，因为他们可以把这条河当作露天污水沟，正因为如此，当你说有机材料时，大量的有机材料被保存了下来，嗯，凉鞋、信件，好吧，这比我预期的要好，嗯，是的，可能还有更多，而且大量这种材料实际上是在离这里步行两分钟的地方被保存下来的。
So we're between Ludgate Hill and Corn Hill. You'd never know it, would you? You'd never know it. So this river rises about two and a half miles north of the Thames, flows due south. And the Roman city basically gathered around it because they could use the river as an open sewer and because of that loads of organic material was preserved when you say organic material um sandals letters okay that's better than i was expecting well yes probably a bit more as well and loads of this material has actually been preserved about two minutes walk from here.
所以如果我们向南走。好的。我们将前往可能是，我的意思是，我认为它是，罗马伦敦有史以来最浪漫、最令人兴奋的发现之一，那是一座密特拉神庙，节目的朋友，他在众神世界杯中出现过。但在那之前，汤姆，不要丢掉关于布狄卡和头骨的故事。所以故事是这样的，她和她的……现在，提醒我一下，我正在努力回忆我九岁时的历史课。
So if we head down southwards. Okay. We'll head to what is probably one of the most, I mean, I think it is, the most romantic and exciting finds ever made in Roman London, which was a temple to Mithras, friend of the show, who featured in the World Cup of Gods. But before that, Tom, do not throw away this story about Boudicca and the skulls. So the story goes that she and her... Now, remind me, I'm trying to remember my nine-year-old history lessons.
她和她的女儿们被罗马人骚扰了，为了报复。她是爱西尼部落的女王，居住在东安格利亚，诺福克，那种地区。她的丈夫普拉苏塔古斯是罗马人民的盟友。当他去世时，罗马人闯入并强奸了布狄卡，强奸了她的女儿。这是一件不明智的事情，因为布狄卡召集了爱西尼人，他们横扫而下，烧毁了
She and her daughters have been molested by Romans and in revenge. She's the queen of a tribe called the Icani, who inhabit East Anglia, Norfolk, that kind of area. And her husband, Prosutagas, is an ally of the Roman people. When he dies, the Romans move in and they rape Boudicca, they rape her daughters. And this is an unwise thing to do because Boudicca raises the Icanians and they sweep down and they burn
科尔切斯特，他们烧毁了伦敦，他们烧毁了维鲁拉米姆（圣奥尔本斯），嗯，看起来整个省的未来都岌岌可危，他们遇到了苏埃托尼乌斯·保利努斯，他，嗯，他一直在安格尔西岛攻击德鲁伊，当消息传到他那里时，他匆忙赶回，遇到了布狄卡的军队并消灭了他们。而那些头骨，那些年轻人，他们是什么，在伦敦被抓住的罗马士兵吗？不，大概是平民。不列颠人是猎头者。它们算是战利品。对，它们大概是……我的意思是，我们不知道，我的意思是，很难确定，很难确定。是的，好吧，我的意思是，关于罗马伦敦，我们对它的理解是基于一种
colchester they burn london they burn uh verlanium st albans um and it looks as though the entire future of the of the province is hanging in the balance and they meet with um sutaneous polinus who is um he's been uh attacking the druids up inlesey and he comes harrying back when the news reaches him and meets with Boudicca's army and wipes them out. And the skulls, the young men, these are what, Roman soldiers who've been caught basically in London? No, presumably they are civilians. The Britons are headhunters. They're kind of trophies. Right're presumably i mean we don't know i mean it's very hard to dance very hard to dance yeah well it's i mean the the thing about roman london our understanding of it is based on a kind of
将文献资料拼凑在一起，是的，这些资料通常非常零碎。所以我们确实有塔西佗关于布狄卡的记载，但随后有整个时期，罗马历史学家根本没有提到这座城市。所以你必须用考古学来填补空白，因为它对他们来说基本上无关紧要，因为它在不列颠，而且很远，谁在乎呢？是的，基本上，基本上，住在这里的人，我的意思是，好吧，几乎没有证据表明是哪种情况，但你的最佳猜测，汤姆，住在这里的人，他们算是罗马-不列颠人吗？他们是凯尔特血统吗？他们是凯尔特起源吗？嗯，我认为，这更有可能是，嗯，我的意思是，当然会有不列颠人住在这里，但也会有
meshing together of documentary sources yeah which are often very fragmentary so we do have tacitus say on on buddhica but then there are whole periods where the city is simply not mentioned at all by roman historians so you have to fill in the gaps with archaeology because it's inconsequential to them basically because it's in britain and it's a long way away and who cares yeah basically basically and the people who lived here i mean okay there's very little evidence one way or the other but your best guess tom the people who lived here they're kind of romano-british are they celtic extraction are they celtic origin well i think it's it's likelier to be um i mean certainly there would be people who are who are british living here but it would also be
很多来自国外的人，会有定居者和商人等等。是的，所以很多，呃，所以他们会是来到这里的原始法国人。嗯，这很有趣，这很有趣，所以可能保存最完好的城墙段——我们稍后会谈到城墙——是在塔山（Tower Hill）那里，作为中世纪城墙结构的一部分嵌入其中的，是一块高卢人的墓碑，他在布狄卡叛乱后来到这里，基本上是为了建立一套不会引发叛乱的税收机构。所以是为了试图让局势平静下来。所以他是进来的殖民行政官，但他是一个高卢人。没错。所以你可以看出，当然，我的意思是，罗马伦敦与高卢的联系比与罗马的联系更紧密。
lots of people from abroad it would be settlers and traders and so on yeah so lots of uh so they would be the proto-french coming over well it's interesting it's interesting there's so probably the best preserved stretch of wall will come to the walls later on is by tower hill there as part embedded in part of the the fabric of the medieval war when it got built was a tombstone of a Gaul who'd come over here in the wake of Boudicca's rebellion to kind of basically set up a tax apparatus that would not provoke rebellion. So to try and kind of calm things down. So he's the colonial administrator who comes in, but he's a Gaul. Right. So you can see how, of course, I mean, Rome and London is connected to Gaul closer than it is to Rome.
所以这里可能有来自意大利的人，但他们更有可能是来自高卢的商人。无论如何，我们现在已经到达了伦敦密特拉神庙外面。这是在50年代被发现的。所以，你知道，闪电战对罗马考古学非常有益，嗯，它被发现了，它再次是在沃尔布鲁克河岸边的城墙遗址附近，这对开发商来说非常非常不方便，你知道，他们不想要一座密特拉神庙，而且它之所以被保存下来，是因为，你知道，正如众神世界杯的听众会记得的那样，基本上密特拉崇拜者有点像共济会，只有男性，它完全是关于那种签约和结交朋友、建立联系之类的事情。
So there are probably people from Italy here, but they're more likely to be traders from Gaul. Anyway, we have now arrived outside the London Mithraeum. And this was found in the 50s. So, you know, the Blitz was tremendously good for roman archaeology um and it was found it was again kind of by the site of the war by the banks of the walbrook and it was very very inconvenient for the developers you know they didn't want a temple to mithras and and the reason that it's preserved is is because you know as listeners to the world cup of gods will remember that basically mithras worshipers are kind of like masons male only um it it's all about kind of signing up and making friends and contacts and that kind of
布鲁克斯是为你准备的，汤姆。嗯，也许有一点，有一点，但神庙位于地下，这座神庙之所以幸存下来就是这个原因，它在考古层中非常深，但对开发商来说很不方便。所以他们把它移走了，把它安置在一条非常繁忙的道路旁边，并用1950年代风格的疯狂铺路石包围了它。所以它看起来一点也不浪漫。但后来当彭博（Bloomberg）来到这里开发这个空间时，规划条件的一部分是他们必须为密特拉神庙提供一个新的空间，他们已经做到了，我必须说，做得非常出色。所以你可以进去。伦敦的任何人都可以参观它。
thing brooks is for you tom well perhaps a little bit a little bit but the temples are situated underground this this temple had survived for that reason it was kind of very deep in the archaeological layer but inconvenient for the developers So they removed it and they situated it next to a very busy road and surrounded it by 1950s style crazy paving. So it could not have looked less romantic. But then when Bloomberg came here and developed this space, and part of the planning condition was that they had to provide a new space for the Mithras temple, which they've done, I have to say, absolutely superbly. So you can go in here. Anyone in London can visit it.
这是一种非常、非常棒的体验。你深入地下。他们设置了声光秀，让你对神庙原本的样子有一个概念。听起来不错，汤姆。它非常好。我们进去吧。别说话了。但我们不会那样做。
It's a really, really excellent experience. You go deep, deep down. They've kind of set up sound and light shows so that you have a sense of what the temple actually looked like. Sounds great, Tom. It is very good. Let's go in. Stop talking. But we're not going to do that.
我们要进去看的是一些从沃尔布鲁克河里取出的有机材料，它们保存在里面。所以，汤姆，我们进来了。对于那些不知道这个地区的人来说，它就在银行地铁站旁边。我们身处城市中心，被巨大的高耸办公楼所包围。这里就是这个看起来很棒的小博物馆。而且，汤姆，对于那些不知道的人，密特拉神庙和密特拉。
What we are going to go in is go and have a look at some of the organic material from the Walbrook, which is preserved inside. So, Tom, we've come inside. And just for people who don't know the area, it's right next to Bank Tube Station. We're in the heart of the city, surrounded by massive towering office blocks. And here is this fantastic looking little museum. And, Tom, for people who don't know, a Mithraeum and Mithras.
所以这是一个非常晦涩的神，不是吗？帝国的鼎盛时期。基本上是军官阶层的一种俱乐部。这样说公平吗？那些男人，那种积极向上、有抱负的罗马男人，那种上尉之类的，他们聚集在什么地方，地下？
So this is this very obscure god, isn't it? The heyday of the empire. Basically a sort of club for the officer class. Is that fair? That men, sort of upwardly mobile, aspirational Roman men, sort of captains and so on, they gather what, underground?
我们不知道他们做什么，他们做些与公牛有关的事情。是的，好吧，密特拉被认为在时间之初杀死了公牛，嗯，呃，密特拉崇拜复制了这一点，所以这座神庙建于公元240年左右，而且它，正如你所说，是一个邪教。我的意思是，我们说它非常像共济会。这是一个你去结识有用之人的地方。它有不同的等级。所以你从底层进入，目标是越来越高。
And we don't know what they do do they something to do with bulls yeah well mithras is meant to have killed the bull at the beginning of time and um uh the cult of mithras kind of replicates this um so this this temple built around um ad 240 um and it's it's uh as you say, a cult. I mean, we said very like the Masons. It's the kind of place where you go and you meet useful people. And it has kind of different grades. So you go in at the bottom and the ambition is to go higher and higher and higher.
在节目开始时，我提到了在不列颠发现的最早的文件，是的，就是这张来自伦敦早期的借据，这就是它，所以你可以在那里看到它，非常令人兴奋，但嗯，在它旁边还有另一张，而且这在某种程度上同样令人兴奋，所以可能来自65年到70年，所以你知道，在布狄卡焚毁城市不到十年后。将近2000年了。而这之所以令人兴奋，是因为这是伦敦文件上第一次提到
At the start of the show, I mentioned the very earliest document ever found uh written in britain yes is this um iou from the very early years of london and this is it so you can see it there very exciting but um next to it there is another one um and this is in a way equally exciting so probably from 65 to to 70 so you know less than a decade after the incineration of the city by Udica. Almost 2,000 years old. And the reason this is exciting is this is the first ever mention on a document from London
伦敦的名字。所以，伦底纽姆（Londinium）。所以我看到了什么，汤姆？因为，我的意思是，它非常非常模糊。这是一块木板，他们用铁笔在上面刻字。是的，所以上面会有蜡，铁笔的印记会在木头上留下痕迹。是的。然后它被扔掉了，被扔进泥里，沉入沃尔布鲁克河的泥里
of the name of London. So, Londinium. So what am I looking at, Tom? Because, I mean, it's very, very faded. It's a wooden tablet and they've scratched on it with a stylus. Yeah, and so there'd be wax on it and the imprint of the stylus would leave marks on the wood. Yeah. And then it gets chucked out, gets thrown into the mud, sinks into the mud of the wall
然后它就被保存了下来。所以每当这里有挖掘工作时，你知道，我们身处城市中心，所以他们总是在建造、挖掘深地基。这些东西就会被翻出来，你可以看到有各种各样的，你知道，所以有硬币，有双耳瓶，你可以看到有各种各样的，你知道，所以有硬币，有双耳瓶，有钥匙，有针梳，有各种各样的，你知道，马赛克，所以各种各样的东西，这是一个奇妙的宝藏，不是吗？是的，它很棒，但我认为，我认为真正动人且有力量的东西是有机材料，否则它们是无法保存下来的
brook and it's then preserved. And so whenever there's excavations here, you know, we're in the heart of the city, so they're always building, digging deep foundations. This stuff gets turned up and you can see there's all kinds of, you know, so there's coins, there's amphorae, there are can see there's all kinds of you know so there's coins there's um there's amphorae there are keys there's knit combs there's all kind you know mosaic so all kinds of stuff it's a fantastic hoard isn't it yeah it's wonderful and but i think i think the stuff that is really moving and powerful is is the organic material which otherwise doesn't survive
所以除了这些书写材料，你还有一支桨，你有一块门板，你有一只凉鞋。是的，凉鞋，那种奇妙的凉鞋保存得非常完好，真的非常非常棒。所以伦敦任何没来过这里的人，这真是一件了不起的事情，它是免费的。我们不会深入到建筑的深处去看密特拉神庙，我们没有被启蒙，不，我们没有，尽管我们是男人，所以我们被允许这样做。对，但部分问题在于我们没有大量的书面材料来解释伦敦历史上发生了什么。所以我们必须从考古学中推断出来。而罗马伦敦鼎盛时期的大多数建筑都已经消失了。所以你真正拥有的只是碎片。
so as well as this writing stuff you've got an oar um you've got a piece of a door and you've got a sandal yeah the sandals kind of wonderful sandals are beautifully preserved really really wonderful um so anyone in london who hasn't been here it's an amazing thing it's free um we're not going to go down into the bowels of the building to look at the mithras temple we haven't been initiated no we haven't although we are men so we are allowed to do it right um but part of the problem is that we don't have huge amounts of written material explaining what's happening in the history of London. So we have to kind of work out from the archaeology. And most of the buildings of Roman London in its heyday have vanished. So all you really have are fragments.
我认为罗马伦敦的魅力的一部分在于你可以感受到它原本的样子。但它也是一个神话和幻想的地方。所以就像，你知道，康拉德想象罗马百夫长沿着泰晤士河口向上航行，跨越了它整个历史的跨度。所以一直到中世纪，经过都铎时期等等。这些后来时期发现的罗马伦敦碎片产生了神话、幻想。所以我想我们现在去休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将去看看一些被保存下来的碎片，它们出现在相当奇怪和有趣的背景中。太好了。我很期待。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I think part of the fascination of Roman London is the way in which you can have a sense of it as it actually was. But it's also a place of myth and fantasy. So rather like, you know, Conrad imagining the Roman centurion coming up the Thames estuary over the entire sweep of its history. So all the way through the Middle Ages, through the Tudor period and so on. These fragments of Roman London that have been found by later periods have generated myths, fantasies. So I think we'll go for a break now. When we come back, we'll go and have a look at a few of the fragments that are preserved and they appear in quite odd contexts and interesting contexts. Excellent. I look forward to it. I'm Marina Hyde.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦，以及在我们的问答环节
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A
我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和抢先获得现场门票，
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余味》。我们身处罗马伦敦的中心。我们在一些道路施工旁边，有卡车。这真是太迷人了。
head to therestisentertainment.com That's therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are in the heart of Roman London. We're by some roadworks, there are lorries. It's incredibly glamorous.
而汤姆·霍兰德，他谈论做这个播客基本上和我认识他一样久了。我太兴奋了。他在他最喜欢的文物之一旁边停了下来，那基本上只是一块大石头。所以，汤姆，告诉我们这块石头。任何对罗马伦敦有兴趣的人都知道看着石块所能带来的快感。这就是它的全部意义所在。所以我们在坎农街火车站对面，我们正在看被称为伦敦石的东西。对，它……这就是它的全部意义所在。所以我们在坎农街火车站对面，我们正在看被称为伦敦石的东西。
And Tom Holland, who's been talking about doing this podcast for basically as long as I've known him. I'm so excited. Has stopped by one of his favorite artifacts, which is basically just a big stone. So, Tom, tell us about this stone. Anyone with any interest in Roman London knows the thrill to be had from looking at lumps of stone. It's what it's all about. So we're opposite Cannon Street Railway Station, and we're looking at what is called the London Stone. Right. It's a it's all about. So we're opposite Cannon Street Railway Station and we're looking at what is called the London Stone.
对，这是整个首都最奇怪、最民俗的东西之一。它第一次被提到，我想，是在12世纪。它曾经是这个伟大的……这个巨大的石头，在12世纪矗立在坎农街中间。人们相信，无论谁，你可以骑马过来，你可以用你的剑触碰它，然后你就会统治伦敦。好吧，我有一个关于这个的好事实，汤姆。你知道吗，在1450年，叛军领袖杰克·凯德，
Right. Which is one of one of the weirdest, most kind of folkloric things to be seen in the whole of the capital. And it's first mentioned, I think, in in the 12th century. And it was this great this huge kind of stone that stood in the 12th century. And it was this great, this huge kind of stone that stood in the middle of Cannon Street. And it was believed that whoever, you could ride up, you could touch it with your sword and then you'd rule London. Well, I have a good fact about this, Tom. Did you know that in 1450, the rebel leader Jack Cage,
领导了一场反对非节目朋友亨利六世的叛乱，他用剑击打它并声称自己是伦敦之主。我知道这一点，因为它写在它旁边的标语牌上，汤姆，不要破坏幻觉。正是如此，嗯，而且你……哦，一辆救护车经过。我想这是警察的历史。多米尼克，你还知道吗，在1742年，伦敦石被移到了街道北侧，最终被安置在这一侧圣斯威辛教堂墙壁的一个壁龛里？你现在非常明显地在读标语牌。是的，是的。
leading a rebellion against non-friend of the show henry the sixth he struck it with his sword and claimed to be lord of london i did know that because it says that on the the placard which is right next to it tom don't spoil the illusion exactly so um and did you oh an ambulance is going past. It's the history of police, I think. Dominic, did you also know that in 1742, the London Stone was moved to the north side of the street and eventually set in an alcove in the wall of St. Swithin's Church on this side? You're very blatantly reading the placard now. Yeah, yeah.
好吧，所以……所以这是一种……这是一种民俗……多么奇怪，这块石头，坦率地说，我说过一块大石头，但它……我的意思是，它没那么大。它基本上是一个非常大的包裹的大小。所以最初它大得多。好吧，在中世纪的过程中，人们一直在从它上面敲下碎片，所有那种……所有那种
Okay, so... So this is this kind of... It's a sort of folkloric... How weird that this one stone, which, frankly, I've said a big stone, but it's... I mean, it's not that big. It's the size of a very large parcel basically so originally it was much larger okay and people have been chipping bits off it over the course of the middle ages all that kind of all that kind of
胡闹，基本上没人知道它是什么或它来自哪里。所以约翰·斯托，伟大的伊丽莎白时代的古物研究者，是的，嗯，他说这块石头被放在那里的原因，时间或其他记忆都没有。所以几个世纪以来，人们提出了各种各样的理论，关于伦敦石是什么。所以都铎时期非常流行的理论是它是由布鲁图斯建立的，那个来到这里并杀死了所有龙的特洛伊人，不列颠的建立者。最近，人们认为它是德鲁伊进行祭祀的一块大石头。其他人说它是帕拉迪翁（Palladium），所以它是
malarkey and basically nobody has any idea what it was or where it came from so john stowe the great elizabethan antiquary yeah um he says the cause why this stone was set there the time when or other memory hereof is none and so over the course of of the centuries people have come up with all kinds of theories as to what the london stone was so very popular theory in the tudor period was it had been set up by brutus um the trojan who came here and killed all the dragons, the founder of Britain. More recently, people have thought that it was a great stone on which the Druids conducted sacrifices. Other people have said that it's the Palladium, so it's the
一种象征城市的石头，如果它被偷了，那么城市就会陷落。所以它是乌鸦的一种石质对应物，嗯，即使是现在，你知道，人们沉迷于地脉之类的东西，你知道，彼得·阿克罗伊德和所有的一切，都对伦敦着迷。我很惊讶我在这里看不到威尔·塞尔夫之类的人。正是如此，嗯，但我们现在站的地方是总督府（Praetorium），也就是总督总部所在的地方，对此没有任何痕迹。不，它只是一个……
kind of a stone that symbolizes the city, and that if it gets stolen, then the city will fall. So it's a kind of lapidary equivalent of the ravens um and and even now they're you know people are into ley lines and that kind of stuff are you know peter akroyd and everything all kind of obsessed with the london i'm surprised i can't see will self here or something like that exactly um but the where we're standing now is where the praetorium, so basically the governor's headquarters would have been, of which there is no trace whatsoever. No, it's just a leon.
理论是，这标志着通往总督总部的入口。所以某种记忆被保存了下来。所以它被保存了下来。所以罗马人离开了。这里有这种巨大的拱门，某种记忆被保存了下来，所以它被保存了下来，所以罗马人离开了，嗯，这里有这种巨大的拱门，它被保存了下来，它沉入了，你知道，撒克逊城镇积累的泥土中，它被当作城市的一种图腾保存了下来。所以如果情况确实如此，那么这就是我们拥有的总督府的唯一碎片，但我们不知道，这既是魅力，我想也是挫败感。伦敦市长应该来这里宣誓就职，
And the theory is that this marked the gateway into the governor's headquarters. And so some sort of memory of that was preserved. And so it was preserved. So the Romans leave. There is this kind of great archway here, sort of memory of that was preserved and so it's it was preserved so so the romans leave um there is this kind of great archway here and it's it's preserved and it kind of sinks into the you know the accumulated dirt of the saxon town um and it's kept as a kind of totem of the city so if if that's the case then this is the only fragment of the praetorium that we have um but we don't know and that is both the kind of the fascination i think the frustration the mayor of london should come and be sworn in
触摸这块石头，不是吗？所以本质上，不像你知道的一些更宏伟的罗马城市，罗马伦敦剩下的东西很少。我们跳得有点远，我知道，在时间上。但原因基本上是当罗马人在黑暗时代离开时，这座城市陷入了彻底的毁灭，对吧？我的意思是……是的，但也是因为现在存在的城市规划本质上是盎格鲁-撒克逊的。所以它根本不对应
touching this stone don't you so essentially unlike you know some of the grander roman cities so little remains of of roman london and we're jumping ahead a bit, I know, in time. But the reason for that is basically that the city falls into total ruin when the Romans leave in the Dark Ages, right? I mean... Yes, but it's also that the city plan as it exists now is essentially Anglo-Saxon. So it doesn't correspond to the
罗马街道规划，而且建筑物被使用，嗯，你知道，它们被拆解了。是的，所以石头被用来建造新的结构，而伦敦的独特之处在于你确实有这种断裂，因为当罗马人离开时，伦敦内部似乎被认为是受诅咒的，你知道，人们不搬到这里，盎格鲁-撒克逊定居点在泰晤士河下游的奥德维奇，然后你只是有这些无休止的灾难循环，淹没了伦敦，所以无休止的火灾，无休止的重建等等，它只是被焚毁了。有痕迹元素。
roman street plan at all and the the buildings are used um you know they're cannibalized yeah so the stone is used to build new the new structures um and the thing that's distinctive about london is that you do have this kind of break because when the romans leave the interior of london seems to have been regarded as as cursed you know people people don't move here the anglo-saxon settlement is further down the thames at aldwych and then you just have these kind of endless cycles of calamity that overwhelms london so endless fires endless rebuildings and so on and it's just it's just kind of incinerated it. There are trace elements.
它们几乎都在地下。所以我们去了密特拉神庙。那真是太棒了。还有圆形剧场，在市政厅。同样，是一个地下博物馆。非常值得一游。圆形剧场有多少留存？你可以看到它的痕迹。
They're almost all underground. So we went to the Mithraeum. That's kind of wonderful. There's also the amphitheater, which is at the Guildhall. And again, is a kind of underground museum. Really worth visiting. How much of the amphitheater is there? You can see traces of it.
痕迹？是的，那个词，痕迹，痕迹，制作人挑起了眉毛。不，我遵循了你的度假建议，我吸取了教训。好吧，让我们说，圆形剧场的留存比总督府的要多。对于那些没听过我们之前播客的人，我应该说去年夏天我的家人去希腊度假，汤姆推荐了斯巴达的一座神庙。他说它绝对精彩。我妻子说，哦，我们先在谷歌地图上查一下。所以我们在谷歌地图上查了，看了街景。田野里大约有四块非常非常低的石头。
Traces? Yeah. That word traces traces the producer's raising his eyebrows no i followed your recommendations on holidays and there are i've learned my lesson okay well let's let's say that there is more of the amphitheater than there is of the um the praetorium for those people who haven't listened to our previous podcast i should say last summer my family went on holiday to g Greece, and Tom recommended a temple in Sparta. He said it was absolutely brilliant. And my wife said, oh, we'll just check it on Google Maps first. So we checked it on Google Maps, had a look at the street view. There were about four very, very low stones in a field.
第一条评论说，流浪汉和吸毒者的热门聚集地。所以我们决定放弃它。我认为这说明你的冒险精神很差。确实。确实。是的。我想我们去了海滩什么的。多米尼克，我想说的是，通过正确的视角，如果一个人心情好，
And the first review said, popular haunt for the homeless and drug addicts. So we decided to give it a miss. I think that speaks very poorly of your sense of adventure. It does. It does. Yeah. I think we went to the beach or something. Dominic, what I would say is that seen through the right lenses, if one is in the right mood,
如果一个人有冒险精神，就有可能接受这样一个事实：缺乏伟大建筑的遗迹本身就是一种浪漫，非常浪漫。所以当我走过这家科斯塔咖啡分行时，想到曾经在这个地方的伟大建筑，我感到很激动。所以实际上我们现在要前往的是，我认为，整个罗马伦敦最浪漫的地方之一。哦。而且它是……别夸大它，汤姆。它是……的痕迹元素。
if one has a spirit of adventure, it's possible to accept that the very lack of uh remnant remnants of a great building is in itself kind of romantic terribly romantic so as i walk past this branch of costa well i feel stirred at the thought of the great buildings that were once on this spot so actually what we're going to head to now is one of the um is one of the most, I think, romantic spots in the whole of Roman London. Oh. And it's... Don't oversell it, Tom. It's a trace element of what was the...
那个词又出现了。阿尔卑斯山以北最大的罗马建筑之一，如果不是最大的话。它是伦底纽姆的巴西利卡，它矗立在……阿尔卑斯山以北的罗马建筑，它是伦底纽姆的巴西利卡，它矗立在广场的中心，我们现在……所以我们正从坎农街向东走，我们刚刚又来到了伦敦桥，所以我们在纪念碑地铁站旁边，所以我们在纪念碑旁边，由伦敦大火纪念碑建造，我们要前往一个我们在本系列节目中已经访问过的地方，也就是利德贺市场。哦，是的，我们在圣诞颂歌那一集里去那里买鹅了，
That word again. One of, if not the largest buildings north of the Alps, Roman buildings north of the Alps. And it was the Basilica of Londinium, which stood in the heart of the alps and it was the basilica of uh of londonium which stood in the heart of the forum and we're now so we're heading um eastwards from cannon street we've just come to to london bridge again so we're by monument tube station so we're by monument by the great monument built to the great fire of london um and we're going to head up to um a place that we've already visited in the course of this series which is leadenhall market oh yeah we went there for our for our goose in the christmas carol episode and
又是那个词。它是阿尔卑斯山以北最大（如果不是最大的话）的罗马建筑之一。它就是伦敦城的巴西利卡，矗立在广场中心。我们现在正从坎农街向东走，刚刚又回到了伦敦桥，所以我们在纪念碑地铁站附近，也就是为了纪念伦敦大火而建的伟大纪念碑旁。我们要前往本系列节目中已经去过的一个地方，那就是利德贺市场。哦，是的，我们在《圣诞颂歌》那一集里去那里买过鹅。
the basilica stood on leadenhall market and you know which is kind of fitting because the basilica served as a market it served as a kind of great assembly point uh it was so people who've been into you know a basilica in uh in in italy kind of you know church yeah structure of churches was modeled on on roman basilicas um it was three stories high so absolutely kind of sumptuous showcase building illustrating for people that um even in the kind of barbarous wilds of this chilly island uh set in the ocean you could have civilized shopping well and as luck would have it there's a marks and spencers just up the road but it's almost almost completely vanished but there is one chunk of it left um and i think we
巴西利卡坐落在利德贺市场，你知道这很贴切，因为巴西利卡曾用作市场，也曾作为一种大型集会点。去过意大利巴西利卡的人都知道，教堂的结构就是仿照罗马巴西利卡建造的。它有三层楼高，绝对是一座富丽堂皇的展示性建筑，向人们展示了即使在这个位于海洋中、寒冷岛屿的野蛮荒原上，你也能享受到文明的购物体验。说来也巧，街上不远处就有一家玛莎百货，但它几乎已经完全消失了，不过还剩下一小部分，我想我们
should go and have a look at it now so tom of all the uh locations you brought me to none has been more unexpected than this this is a um well it's a barber shop there's no there's no way of uh selling it otherwise nicholson and griffin men's grooming um it looks excellent actually so we're in leadenhall market now this was always my favorite spot when i did tours of roman london for the uh the the children of the primary school that my daughters went to and we'd they'd come here that dad i was that dad the other dads all hated i was like it was always there to let him do fun things with the kids this is this is what this was the one thing i do every time we go on a tour of roman london and they you know 30 of them little crocodile and they come
现在应该去看看。汤姆，在你带我去的这么多地方中，没有哪个比这里更出人意料了。这是一家……嗯，理发店，除此之外没法形容了。尼科尔森与格里芬男士理容店，看起来确实很棒。我们现在在利德贺市场，当我为我女儿所在小学的孩子们做罗马伦敦之旅的导游时，这里一直是我最喜欢的地方。我会带他们来这儿，我就是那种其他爸爸都很讨厌的爸爸，我总是带孩子们做些有趣的事情。这是我每次带罗马伦敦之旅时必做的一件事，他们，你知道，30个小家伙排成一队，他们来到
here and we'd stand outside the nicholson griffin men's grooming and um they would let us go down into the basement so you'd have a little crocodile of children would head down solemnly into the basement see what is down in the basement and then solemnly come back up and we can now replicate that so that explains tom why just by the in the barbers i can see a photo of you on the wall with a sign saying do not open the door to this man listeners he is lying let's go in let's go in and see what's downstairs so fighting our way across the customers everywhere and in the corner what do we what do we see there it is so that's the basilica so so what we're seeing is we've got we've got people having their hair cut. Talking about the holidays. Basins and stuff. And then there's a kind of glass door.
这里，我们站在尼科尔森与格里芬男士理容店外面，他们会让我们下到地下室。于是，一队小孩子庄重地走进地下室，看看地下室里有什么，然后又庄重地走上来。我们现在可以重现这一幕。那么汤姆，这就解释了为什么在理发店里，我能看到墙上挂着你的照片，上面写着“不要给这个人开门，听众们，他在撒谎”。我们进去吧，进去看看楼下有什么。在顾客中间挤过去，在角落里我们看到了什么？就在那儿，那就是巴西利卡。所以我们看到的是，有人在理发，谈论着假期，还有洗脸盆之类的东西。然后有一扇玻璃门。
And beyond the door, there is a chunk of recognizably Roman masonry. You can tell it's Roman because very kind of thin, narrow bricks. Yeah. And that is all that remains of the largest building built by the Romans north of the Alps. Tom, I take my hat the roman basilica you've not oversold this at all and it is more than a trace yeah it's quite a good bit of wall and it's behind this sort of uh glass door so it's clearly quite nicely preserved you can come and have your haircut and then go and admire it it's it's absolutely the place to come for your haircut
门后是一块清晰可辨的罗马砖石。你可以看出它是罗马时期的，因为砖块非常薄且窄。是的，这就是罗马人在阿尔卑斯山以北建造的最大建筑仅存的部分。汤姆，我向你致敬，你对这座罗马巴西利卡的介绍一点都没有夸大，它不仅仅是一点痕迹，确实是一段相当不错的墙体，而且它就在这扇玻璃门后面，所以保存得相当完好。你可以来理个发，然后去欣赏它，这绝对是理发的绝佳去处。
it's wonderful salon and it provides you with a little bit of Roman archaeology as well. What more could a gentleman want? Even a producer who is the soul of cynicism is looking wide-eyed with excitement. I think he's actually just had a haircut,
这是一家很棒的沙龙，它还为你提供了一点罗马考古知识。一位绅士还能要求什么呢？就连那位愤世嫉俗的制作人现在也瞪大了眼睛，充满兴奋。我想他其实刚理过发，
which is a shame because otherwise he can come down here and have a haircut. Have a haircut and penance. And the thing that's great is that there's a statue of Apollo,
这很可惜，因为否则他可以下来理个发。理个发，顺便忏悔一下。最棒的是旁边架子上有一尊阿波罗雕像，
a bust of Apollo on the ledge next to it. And there's a picture on the wall of the Basilica. It looks, was it as big as this, Tom? Yeah. That's huge. Yeah. It was a really, really huge structure. So, I mean, the size, I mean, what's that, the size of a football stadium, roughly? Yeah.
一个阿波罗半身像。墙上还有一张巴西利卡的图片。它看起来……汤姆，它有这么大吗？是的。太巨大了。是的，它是一个非常、非常巨大的结构。我的意思是，它的大小，大概相当于一个足球场那么大？是的。
Yes. And so that was the centre of... And perfectly square. So the Roman Forum was perfectly square. Oh, so sorry, that picture is not the Basilica, it's the Forum. Yeah, it's the Forum. Well, it's the Basilica in the middle
是的。所以那是……的中心。而且是完美的正方形。所以罗马广场是完美的正方形。哦，抱歉，那张图片不是巴西利卡，是广场。是的，是广场。嗯，巴西利卡在中间，
and then you've got the Forum all around it. Yeah. And of course, that is a contrast with the modern city because notoriously the street plan of the city of London is an absolute mess. It's not a grid. So this is beautifully laid out. So this is much more a kind of manhattan style yeah um and the the the anglo-saxon street plan which has
然后周围是广场。是的。当然，这与现代城市形成了鲜明对比，因为众所周知，伦敦的街道布局简直是一团糟。它不是网格状的。所以这个布局非常漂亮。这更像是一种曼哈顿风格。是的，取代它的盎格鲁-撒克逊街道布局，你知道，这就是为什么在城里很难走动，你总是会迷路。但在罗马时期，它更像是一个网格模式。所以这里，它告诉你，这个支撑柱或桥墩是罗马伦敦巴西利卡唯一幸存的部分，曾作为巴西利卡拱廊中一个拱门的基座。这里曾是罗马伦敦的市政厅、法院和中央市场。建于公元70年。从公元90年到120年进行了扩建。成为了阿尔卑斯山以北最大的
replaced it is you know that's why it's so difficult to get around the city you always get lost but back in the roman period much more of a grid pattern and so you've got here um it tells you about it this support or pier is the only surviving part of roman london's basilica served as the base of an arch in one of the Basilica's arcades. Housed Roman London's town hall, law courts, central market. Built in AD 70. It was enlarged from AD 90 to 120. Became the largest
此类建筑。所以就是这样。是的，我向你脱帽致敬。好吧，我想罗马伦敦还有一大景点值得一看。那就是城墙，它建于……罗马伦敦的一大景点，那就是城墙，它建于2世纪末，可能是由一个叫克洛狄乌斯·阿尔比努斯的人建造的。
such building north of the Alps. So there you go. Yeah. I'll take my hat off to you. Okay. So I think there's one more of the great sights of Roman London to see. And that is the Wall, which was built towards the end of the great sites of Roman London to see, and that is the Wall, which was built towards the end of the 2nd century, possibly by a guy called Clodius Albinus.
所以他是个篡位者，对吧？是的，克洛狄乌斯·阿尔比努斯，克洛狄乌斯·白，克洛狄乌斯·苍白。是的，他挑战了塞普蒂米乌斯·塞维鲁，后者后来也来到了英国，并死在了这里，死在约克。克洛狄乌斯·阿尔比努斯结局很惨，但很有可能就是他，因为他是英国总督，他建造了城墙，这样伦敦就可以作为一位准皇帝的合适首都。那太荒谬了。
So he's a usurper, is he? Yes, Clodius the White, Clodius the Pale. Yes, so he took on Septimius Severus, who himself subsequently came to britain and actually died here died in york um and uh claudius albinus came to a grisly end but uh it's very possible that he was the guy um because he was governor of britain um that he he built the wall so that london could serve as a a kind of fitting capital capital for a would-be emperor. That would be ridiculous.
我的意思是，把伦敦作为首都对一位准罗马皇帝来说太荒谬了，对吧？是的，但他刚开始，所以他想……我的意思是，有点像君士坦丁，他也是在约克被拥立为皇帝。有一种说法，你知道，圣杰罗姆称英国为“暴君的摇篮”，因为它有三个
I mean, to have London as your capital would have been ridiculous for a would-be Roman emperor, right? Yeah, but he's starting off, so he wants to... I mean, a bit actually, you know, kind of like Constantine as well, who is proclaimed emperor in York. There is this idea, you know, St Jerome calls Britain the nursery of tyrants because it has three
军团。因此，对于一个想篡位的人来说，这是一个非常非常有用的地方，你可以去征服高卢，然后希望像君士坦丁那样进军意大利。所以城墙必须……我不认为罗马伦敦在二世纪末受到任何军事威胁，但城墙的建造是为了作为一种象征。是的。一个宏伟、显赫的首都。地位，威望。地位必须有城墙。
legions. And so therefore it's a very, very useful place for a would-be usurper to have, you know, you can go conquer Gaul and then hopefully move on to Italy as Constantine does. But, and so the walls have to, you know, I don't think that Roman London was under any military threat at the end of the second century, but the walls were built to serve as a symbol. Yeah. A grand prestigious capital. Status, prestige. Status had to have walls.
这些城墙基本上……我的意思是，它们一直存在到最近。所以城门，你知道，你有勒德门、纽盖特、主教门、阿尔德门，所有这些城门都保留了现存城墙的痕迹。正如我提到的，塔山附近有一大块非常可观的部分。是的。还有其他痕迹。多米尼克，我想带你去看看我认为最浪漫、最出人意料的城墙部分。而且，
And these walls provided essentially, I mean, they lasted up until quite recently. So the gates, you know, so you have Ludgate, you have Newgate, you have Bishop's Gate, Allgate, all these gates preserve the trace elements of the wall that existed. They're a very, very sizable chunk, as I think I mentioned, by Tower Hill. Yeah. And there are other traces as well. And I want to take you, Dominic, to see what I think is the most romantic, the most unexpected chunk of the wall. And again,
我们需要去地下。太好了，我很期待。汤姆，我们一直沿着罗马城墙的路线走。非常令人兴奋。但在那一刻的兴奋中，发生了一件我们完全无法预料的非凡戏剧性事件，我们在红绿灯处停了下来，谁会想到呢？你想讲这个故事吗？王，我们的一位“王”詹姆斯，我想他在市政厅工作，是的，拦住我们并说了那句我想我们俩一生都在等待听到的话：“我是你们的王之一”。所以，詹姆斯，如果你听到了，很高兴见到你，希望你喜欢这个节目。顺便解释一下，制作人说，在我们因为说疯话而被取消之前，
it will require us to go underground. Excellent. I look forward to it. So, Tom, we've been walking along the line of the Roman wall. Very exciting. But a moment of excitement, an extraordinary drama that we couldn't possibly have anticipated we stopped at some traffic lights and who should be there but would you want to tell the story a wang one of our wangs james who i think works at the guild hall yeah um stopped us and said the sentence that i think both of us have been waiting all our lives to hear i'm one of your wangs so so james if you uh if you hear this uh it was great to meet you um and uh i hope you're enjoying this show and just to explain the producers say just before we're cancelled on
“王”们是“不安分历史俱乐部”的成员，你当然可以在restlesshistorypod.com加入。詹姆斯，价格非常合理，是的，詹姆斯会告诉你，这简直是……花生价。可以得到各种各样的款待和乐趣，我们正在赠送它们。现在回到罗马城墙，我们沿着城墙走，我们到了这里，这确实是一段真正的城墙，汤姆，它确实不仅仅是一点痕迹。虽然我们现在在巴比肯，巴比肯的名字来源于一个拉丁词，晚期拉丁词“Barbicana”，意思是瞭望塔。好的。
the grounds of just saying demented mad stuff um the wangs are members of the restless history club which you can of course join at restless history pod.com james very reasonable price yeah it's james will tell you it is practically yeah peanuts get all kinds of treats and delights we're giving them away uh now back to the roman wall we've walked along the course of the wall and here we are and it is actually a genuine bit of wall tom it is genuinely more than a trace although what we're so we're now on the barbican and um the barbican takes its name uh from a latin word a late latin Latin word, Barbicana, which is a watchtower. Okay.
它建于罗马时期末期。但我们现在看到的这段城墙实际上并不是罗马人建造的。哦。所以我们看到的是城垛，这是由节目的朋友爱德华四世建造的。天哪，汤姆，这太令人失望了。但中世纪的城墙当然是建立在……节目的朋友爱德华四世。天哪，汤姆，这太令人失望了。
It was built towards the end of the Roman period. But the stretch of wall that we're looking at now is not actually built by the Romans. Oh. So we're looking at crenellations and this was built by a friend of the show, Edward IV. Oh my word, Tom, this is incredibly disappointing. But the medieval wall, of course, is built on the friend of the show, Edward IV. Oh, my word, Tom. This is incredibly disappointing.
但中世纪的城墙当然是建立在罗马城墙的路线上的。对。所以罗马城墙是……砖块不对，对吧？它们不是罗马人那种非常低矮的砖块。所以，一次又一次，罗马城市埋在地下，因为有这种堆积。我带你来这里的原因是我们就在克里普尔门东边。为什么叫克里普尔门？嗯，根据我们伊丽莎白时代的古物研究者朋友斯托的说法，它源于在那里乞讨的残疾人。好吧，他是这么说的。我的意思是，这似乎
But the medieval wall, of course, is built on the line of the Roman wall. Right. So the Roman wall is... The bricks are wrong, aren't they? They're not the same very low kind of bricks that the Romans were. So, you know, again and again, the Roman city lies underground because there's been this kind of accumulation. The reason I brought you here is we're just um we're just east of cripplegate so why is it called cripplegate well according to stowe our antiquarian friend from the elizabethan period it derives from the cripples begging there all right that's what he says i mean that seems
是最不可能的解释。我真的这么认为，我觉得人们根本不知道它为什么叫这个名字。但克里普尔门，我们现在在罗马堡垒的遗址上。所以罗马堡垒是在公元120年左右城墙建造之前建造的。城墙的路线与堡垒连接起来。所以，你知道，这个守卫城市的驻军，保护着总督，这是罗马行省的关键中心。但我带你去看一段真正的、地道的罗马城墙。当你说是地道的时候，我是说，这是地道的吗？
the most improbable explanation really i think so i think he's i don't i think people have no idea why it has that name. But Cripplegate, we're now on the site of the Roman fort. So the Roman fort was built before the walls were built around AD 120. And the walls kind of, the line of the wall was joined up with the fort. And so that, you know, this garrison protecting the city, protecting the governor, this kind of crucial center of the Roman province. But I want to take you to see one particular stretch of authentic, act Roman wall. When you say authentic, I mean, is this authentic?
它是正宗的罗马城墙。好的。但要做到这一点，不出所料，我们必须去地下。好的，你总是引诱我进地下室。好的，多米尼克，我带你进一步向西走。我们现在在伦敦一个多层停车场的入口处。好吧，它不是多层停车场，但它是一个地下停车场。我们在伦敦博物馆旁边，那里有中世纪城墙的另一部分。所以这是爱德华四世的城墙，其实我想这甚至是近代早期的，我想这是都铎时期的。总之，我们现在在伦敦墙停车场。永远不要说我们不去最异国情调和迷人的地方。所以我们要进停车场了，我们直接
It is properly Roman. OK. But to do that, unsurprisingly, we have to go underground. OK, you're always luring me into basements okay so dominic i've i've brought you further um further westwards we're now um yeah we're outside the london entrance into a multi-story car park that is it well it's not a multi-story car park but it is it is an underground car park we're by the museum of london there's another chunk of the of the medieval wall so this is edward the over the fourth wall actually i think this is actually um i think this is um maybe even early modern i think it's it's um tudor yeah i think this is tudor anyway we're now at the london wall car park never let it be said that we don't go to the most exotic and glamorous locations um so we're going into the car park um and we're directly
在路线下方。所以我们头顶上的街道叫伦敦墙。是的，所有这一段都在闪电战中被炸毁了。那条叫伦敦墙的路，基本上沿着伦敦墙的路线，在闪电战之前并不存在。所以这都是城市重建的一部分，包括巴比肯的建设。是的。所以巴比肯，对于那些不知道的人，不知道伦敦的人来说，是一个巨大的综合体，
under the line so so this the street overhead us is called london wall yeah and all of this stretch got blitzed the road that is called london wall which is basically runs along the line of the london wall um didn't exist before the Blitz. So this is all part of the city redevelopment that included the building of the Barbican. Yeah. So the Barbican, for those people who don't know, who don't know London, is this sort of colossal complex,
这是一种纪念碑，对吧，纪念60年代的精神，不是吗？是的。它有点半野兽派。众所周知，你会迷路。你只是……我迷路了，众所周知，你会迷路，是的，我迷路过很多次。是的，这是一个野兽派迷宫。所以这个停车场是作为重建的一部分建造的。再一次，你知道，这一集里一个熟悉的故事，
this sort of monument, isn't it, to the 60s kind of spirit, isn't it? Yeah. It's kind of semi-brutalist. Famously, you get lost. You just kind of... I got lost in famously you get lost you just yeah kind of i've got a lot of many times yes um it's a brutalist maze so but this car park was built as part of the redevelopment uh and once again you know a familiar story on this episode uh
开发商发现了一些意想不到的东西，那就是原始罗马城墙的一块。汤姆，你难道不觉得在19世纪，当他们挖掘地铁等等的时候，一定有太多的东西被摧毁了吗？我的意思是，想象一下一定丢失了多少罗马文物。是的，我想那时如果你在挖地基时发现了罗马遗迹，你可能会保留它，给古物研究者几块，然后继续你的工作。是的，你会的。我的意思是，这是一个……你知道，有趣的是，考虑到英国在罗马时期是一个非常边缘的行省，非常小的行省，我们对英国考古学的了解可能比任何其他类似的行省都要多，因为为了保护而制定的法律
the developers found uh something unexpected which was a chunk of the original roman wall tom does it not occur to you that there must have been so much destroyed in the 19th century yeah when they were digging the underground and so on i mean imagine the roman artifacts that must have been lost yeah i think back then if you were digging foundations and you discovered some roman remains you i mean you'd probably keep it you give a few chunks of it to an antiquarian and then you just get on with the business yeah you would i mean it's an you know interestingly bearing in mind that britain in in the roman period was a very peripheral province very kind of minor province we probably know more about uh the archaeology of britain than we do of any other comparable province really because the um the laws that have been brought in to conserve
非常完善，而且一直很好。这个国家的古物研究传统非常悠久，所以我们实际上对罗马不列颠了解很多。所以我忍不住觉得我们只是在地下停车场里无休止地跋涉。所以我们一直在穿过这个停车场，有停车位，我们现在到了34号，现在到了35号，所以这可能是最令人兴奋的播客。
right are so good and have been so good um and the tradition of antiquarianism in this country is is is so venerable that we actually know quite a lot about roman britain um and and that's so i can't i can't help feeling that we're just trudging endlessly through an underground car park. So we've been trudging through this car park and there are bays, so we've got to 34 now and now we've got to 35, so this is probably the most thrilling podcast
从来没有这么令人兴奋过，我们只需要再往前走一点，多米尼克，你就会看到真正令人惊奇的东西。但问题是我们现在只到了38号，我们还能谈论什么来维持这个过程呢？好吧，我告诉你关于哈德良的事。所以，哈德良著名地来到英国，并建造了他的城墙。但在他到达之前，或者可能就在他到达之前，伦敦似乎发生过火灾。
has never been more exciting and we just need to go a little bit further on and Dominic, you will see something truly astonishing. But the problem is we've now only reached 38 and we still what can we talk about to keep this going um well okay i'll tell you about hadrian yeah so um hadrian famously comes to it uh comes to britain uh and builds his wall. But it seems that during, either before or probably before, just before he arrives, there seems to have been fires in London.
是的。所以他很可能资助了大部分重建工作。目前还不清楚这些火灾是那种经常发生的孤立事故，还是可能发生过某种起义，我们只是不知道。这可能是时候告诉听众我穿着新鞋了，它们痛得难以置信，而我穿着徒步靴。所以当汤姆低声谈论哈德良时，我只是在无声的痛苦中，直到他继续跋涉。好的，穿过这个
Yep. And so he may well have sponsored much of the redevelopment. And it's unclear whether these fires were just kind of isolated accidents of the kind that happened all the time or whether perhaps there'd been some uprising we just don't know this is probably the point to which i should tell the audience that i'm wearing new shoes yeah that are unbelievably painful whereas i'm wearing walking boots so while tom is whispering on about adrian i'm just in mute agony until he continues to trudge okay through this
地下停车场，我们现在到了48号，我们必须到49、50、51，在52号停车位，我们到了旅程的终点。多米尼克，我想你会同意这是值得跋涉的，值得水泡，值得在地下停车场非常不浪漫的环境中苦干，来看看我们有什么。所以告诉我们，我们这里有什么？这只是一段墙，不是吗？我的意思是，它确实是一段墙。所以这是罗马时期的，我的意思是，你可以通过……再次，你有这些非常长、扁平、低矮的砖块，不是吗？任何去过那里的人都能认出来。但我的意思是，你听起来并不印象深刻。
underground car park we've now reached 48 what do we have to get to 49 50 51 and at bay 52 we are at journey's end and Dominic I think you will agree that it's worth the trudge it's worth the blisters it's worth the uh the slog along the very unromantic environs of an underground car park to see what we have so tell us what tell us what we have here it's just a bit of war isn't it i mean it is a bit of war so this is roman i mean you can sort of tell by the, again, you've got these very long kind of flat low bricks, haven't you? Very recognizable to anyone who's been to it. But I mean, do you not, I mean, you're not sounding impressed.
我认为这是在停车场里能发现的最令人惊奇的事情。这是一块占据两个停车位的罗马城墙。这非常感人。是的，你是对的。他们建造了……他们围绕它建造了停车场。他们围绕城墙建造了停车场。周围有几辆旧滑板车。好吧，我以为你会对这个印象更深刻。
I think this is the most amazing thing to find in a car park. It's a chunk of Roman wall occupying two bays. It's very moving. Yeah, you're right. And they've built, you know, the... They've built the car park around it. They've built the car park around the wall. There's a few old scooters around. Okay, I thought you'd be more impressed by this.
我认为他们把它围起来有点令人失望。是的，但这增加了整体氛围。前面有一个巨大的标志写着：伦敦市，禁止停车。好吧，显然你不能停在那里，因为有一块罗马城墙。是的，有人在墙旁边乱涂乱画，写着“优先”。好吧，我认为这是伦敦市的一大景点，但要绝对清楚，如果你从，比如说，
I think the fact they fenced it off was a bit disappointing. Yeah, but it kind of adds to the whole ambience. There's just a bloody big sign in front saying, City of London, no parking. Well, obviously you can't park there because there's a chunk of roman wall yeah somebody's scribbled a bit of graffiti next to the wall that says oddly priority okay well i i think this is one of the great sites of of not just the city of london but just to be absolutely clear if you're flying to london from let's say
美国度假飞往伦敦，直接来这里。我不认为这应该……是的。我不认为它应该排在前十名。我认为应该。什么，在……之上？好吧，伦敦塔和威斯敏斯特教堂太明显了，但你想在停车场看一块罗马城墙。
america on holiday yeah go straight here I don't think this should be... Yeah. I don't think it should be in your top ten. I think it should. What, above... Well, the Tower of London and Westminster Abbey, it's too obvious, but you want to see a chunk of Roman wall in a car park.
这就是你要来的地方。是的，你的孩子们会感谢你的。好吧，多米尼克，你是《神秘博士》的粉丝。是的。所以你离开这里的方式，我们穿过这边的门，有一个非常、非常《神秘博士》风格的通道。我们要去……离开这里，我们穿过这边的门，有一个非常、非常《神秘博士》风格的通道。
This is where you come. Yeah, your children will thank you for it. Well, Dominic, you're a Doctor Who fan. Yeah. So the way that you get out of that, we go through a door over here and there is a very, very Doctor Who passageway. And what we're going you get out of that, we go through a door over here and there is a very, very Doctor Who passageway.
我们要做的现在是……天哪，他还在继续。好吧，我只是想让你看看那个《神秘博士》通道。你可能对那个比对那块墙更兴奋。好的。哦，实际上很黑。
And what we're going to do now... Oh God, he's still going. Well, I just want you to see the Doctor Who passageway. You might be more excited about that than the chunk of wall. Okay. Oh, it's actually quite dark.
也许我们不应该走这里。你确定这是……不，这不理智。不，这不理智。这不理智。通常……哦，我们只是给多米尼克展示一下它有多像《神秘博士》。哦，是的，那不理智。不，这不理智。这不理智。通常……哦，我们只是给多米尼克展示一下它有多像《神秘博士》。
Maybe we shouldn't go long here. You sure this is... No, this is not sensible. No, this is not sensible. This is not sensible. Normally... Oh, we'll just show Dominic how Doctor Who it is. Oh yeah, that is not sensible. No, this is not sensible. This is not sensible. Normally... Oh, we'll just show Dominic how Doctor Who it is.
哦，是的，那相当……是的。相当阴森，不是吗？我不知道我们能不能出去。我们去看看吧。也许不行。托尼，我不会关那扇门。天哪，这里有个戴立克。
Oh, yeah, that is quite... Yeah. It's quite spooky, isn't it? I don't know if we can get out. Let's go and find out. Maybe not. Tony, I wouldn't shut that door. Oh, my God, and here's a Dalek.
多米尼克，我还有一个地方要带你看，那是一个非常感人的景象，意想不到的景象，把我们带回了……是在停车场吗？不，不是。我们走吧。所以多米尼克，我们一直在看罗马伦敦辉煌时期的亮点，但在节目结束时，我们旅行的终点，我带你来到了小黄瓜大厦的脚下，这个形状奇怪的塔楼，不仅仅是小黄瓜的脚下，汤姆，我们就在一栋写着巨大银色字母“荷兰大厦”的建筑外面。是的，好吧，还有哪里？绝对是我在伦敦最喜欢的地方，也是我应该住的地方，我讨厌
I've got one more place, Dominic, to show you, and that is a kind of very moving sight, unexpected sight that takes us back is it to the end of is it in a car park no it's not let's do it so dominic we've been seeing um highlights of the great days of roman london but for the end of the show the end of our tour I've brought you to the foot of the gherkin this kind of weird shaped tower in and not just the foot of the gherkin Tom we are literally right outside a building that says in gigantic silver letters Holland house yeah well where else absolutely my favorite place in London and properly where I should be living and I hate
有一天搬进去接管它。但多米尼克，我带你来这里的原因是你现在实际上正站在一座坟墓上。天哪，所以埋在这里……所以我们在小黄瓜前面看到的是一块黑色铺路石，上面有一个月桂花环，旁边有一些刻着字的大理石，你用拉丁文写着：“致死者的灵魂，来自罗马伦敦的不知名年轻女孩埋葬于此”。翻译过来是：致死者的灵魂，来自罗马伦敦的不知名年轻女孩埋葬于此。所以故事是什么，汤姆？当他们挖掘时，又是……你知道，一次又一次，这是关于开发商挖掘东西，并愤怒地发现罗马城市的痕迹。
one day to to move in take it over but dominic the reason i've brought you here you are actually now standing you're standing on a grave oh my word so buried here so what we've got at the in front of the gherkin there is a a black paving slab with um a kind of laurel wreath on it and then next to it there is some marble engraved and you've got in latin these manibus puella incognita londoniansis hicksapulta est translation to the spirits of the dead the unknown young girl from roman london lies buried here so what's the story tom so when they would dig and again it's you know again and again it's about developers digging stuff up and to their fury discovering traces of the roman city
他们在这里发现的是非常非常令人惊奇的东西，那就是一个年轻女孩的坟墓。这很奇怪，因为罗马人不会把人埋在城市范围内。是的，他们把他们埋在……所以这里有一个线索，她可能是基督徒，因为那些早期的禁忌在基督徒中盛行得少得多。对。果然，当他们对骨骼进行测年时，发现她生活在350年到400年之间。
and what they found here was something really really amazing which was the grave of of a young girl um and that's odd because the romans did not bury people within the city limits yeah they buried them so there's a clue there that probably she is Christian because those kind of earlier taboos prevailed much less with Christians. Right. And sure enough, when they dated the bones, they found that they dated her to 350, 400.
所以她可能是基督徒是合理的。是的，所以那是罗马不列颠的末期。当时的伦敦城已经衰落了。我们在城墙范围内，但也许到那时，人口已经在减少，建筑物被让给了市场花园。所以我们可以想象，这是一个……分配地，是的，完全正确，也许已经变成了废墟。是的，完全正确。所以，罗马伦敦最后几十年的活动焦点会是在港口方向，码头方向。而我们离那里更远，所以你可以想象这在四世纪末可能已经是农业用地了。但她的故事，我认为，我的意思是，这非常感人，这作为这次旅行的完美结尾，因为我们一次又一次地说，另一个主题是人们如何将幻想投射到他们发现的这些奇怪的痕迹上。所以发生的事情是，她的遗骸在伦敦博物馆存放了大约三年，然后在2007年，小黄瓜大厦建成后，他们为她举行了宗教仪式。所以有一个追悼会。什么宗教？嗯，所以在奥尔德门拐角处的圣博托尔夫教堂为她举行了追悼会。有一场盛大的游行
So it's plausible she could have been a Christian. Yeah, and so it's towards the end of Roman Britain. And the city of London by this point was in decline decline we are within the limits of the city walls but perhaps by this point you know already the population is falling uh buildings are kind of being given up to market gardens so what we can imagine is sort of this is an area of what allotments yes exactly maybe already becoming ruined yeah exactly kind of so so um the the focus of of activity in the very very kind of last decades of roman london would have been down towards the port down towards the docks um and we are further up from that so you can imagine that this would
从教堂来到这里。所以有牧师和各种各样的人。但也有市长夫人。他们来到这里，把她安葬在我们现在站的这块石板下面。市长夫人向她撒了玫瑰花瓣。这就是市长夫人认为罗马人会做的事吗？我想是吧。嗯，你必须创造传统，不是吗？他们基本上是在发明一个罗马人。
perhaps be kind of agricultural land by by the end of the fourth century but the story her story is i think i mean it's very touching and it kind of it's a perfect end for this tour because again and again we've also been saying another theme is is how people kind of project fantasies onto these strange trace elements that they find so what happened with this was that that her remains were put into storage in the museum of london for about i think about three years and then 2007 once the Gherkin had been completed, they held a religious ceremony for her. So there was a memorial service. Of what religion? Well, so there was a memorial service held for her at St. Bottles Church, which is around the corner at Aldgate. And there was a full-blown procession
你必须发明传统。罗素·克劳来了，撒了一些土。最棒的是，自从19世纪中期以来，就一直禁止在城市范围内埋葬人，但他们在2007年制定了一项特别规定，你可以在这里埋葬人，如果该地点的先前居住者已经在那里超过75年，你就可以重复使用墓地。所以显然对她来说是可以的，因为她已经在那里待了1600年了。所以，开发商与考古学、物质发现与幻想的交集。
from the church that came here. So there were vicars and all kinds of people. But there was also the Lady Mares. And they came here and laid her beneath this slab that we're standing next to now. And the Lady Mares scattered rose petals over her. Is that what the Lady Mares thought Romans would have done? I think so. Well, you have to kind of create traditions, don't you? They're basically inventing a Roman now.
这是这一集的故事，不是吗？这是这一集的故事。这是一个非常忧郁、令人难忘的结尾。是的，它提醒我们，罗马伦敦本质上是逐渐消失和消退的，我们并不真正知道发生了什么。好吧，我们将在未来的播客中继续讲述伦敦的故事，不是吗？我们会。当我们结束时，我们将经历首都历史的每一个时期。但我认为现在我们会说，你怎么说？Valete，Valete et quae
You have to invent traditions. Russell Crowe came and scattered some soil and the wonderful thing was is that is that um uh so ever since the mid 19th century yeah there's been a ban on burying people within the limits of the city but they they put in a special provision that um uh in in um in in 2007 that you could you could um you could bury people here um you could reuse burial plots if the previous occupant on the site had been there for more than 75 years and so obviously with her you could because she'd been here for kind of 1600 years so um that kind of intersection of developers and archaeology, of material finds and fantasy.
Valete，就是这样，你从当事人那里听到了。再见，感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。如需额外剧集、抢先体验、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在restishistorypod.com注册。那是restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。
It's the story of this episode, isn't it? It's the story of this episode. It's a nicely kind of melancholy, haunting note on which to end. Yes, and it reminds us that essentially Roman London fades away and ebbs away, and we don't really know what happens. Well, we will be taking up the story of london in future podcasts won't we we will by the time we finish we'll have been through every period of the capital's history but i think for now we would say what do you say valet valet at quay
如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和现场门票的抢先体验，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
valet there you go you heard it from the horse's mouth goodbye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening and access to our chat community please sign up at rest is history pod.com that's rest isistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
代客泊车，你听到了吧，这可是出自当事人之口。再见，感谢收听《历史余温》。如需收听奖励剧集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余温》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你想享受无广告收听、奖励剧集和抢先购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。